ви бачите порожню залу Ось так от слуги
ходять на роботу хоча засідання
парламенту відбуваються лише двічі на
місяць І сьогодні тут обговорюється дуже
важливе питання от зараз е-е
дискутується проект бюджету на 23-й рік
зміни до нього яким збільшується видатки
не лише на сектор безпеки що безумовно
Ми підтримуємо на сектор оборони вірніше
але і на абсолютно дикі та молодійські
статті корупційні зокрема мільйони
мільйони десятки і сотні мільйонів
гривень додаються до Міністерства
Юстиції до Бепо інших репресивних
органів хоча очевидно що всі видатки
мають сьогодні ти виключно на сектор
оборони Ну як бачите слух немає дуже
важливо що на наше запитання така навіщо
Міністерство юстиції ще 100 мільйонів
гривень додаткових
відповідь що це потрібно на утримання
російських військовополонених серйозно
гроші податки в тому числі і родин
загиблих наших воїнів будуть іти на
утримання цих вбивць які і сьогодні оно
розстріляли на скутенс очевидно що ці
кошти які потрібно дійсно російський
військовополонені згідно женерських
конвенцій мають утримуватися в
спеціальних таборах і кошти на це точно
може виділити Міжнародний комітет
Червоного Хреста тільки про це треба
працювати з міжнародними гуманітарними
організаціями але от бачимо
професійність зеленої влади власне Наша
команда в залі От дивіться будь ласка
депутати європейського солідарності ми
працюємо по поправкам і на жаль жодну з
наших поправок слуги не прийняли А ми
говоримо про те що потрібно забрати всі
кошти з репресивних органів з лобінських
структур і переправити їх виключно на
створення сили України також ми
зареєстрували законопроект аби
переформатувати телеканал Рада який не
показує парламент який не розповідає про
роботу парламенту і усіх 150 мільйонів
перепрофілювати на збройні сили України
а канал Рада має існувати як в усіх
європейських країнах просто в Ютубі
такий парламентський бюлетень де
показувати трансляцію Верховної Ради
України Вибачте трансляцію Верховної
Ради комітетів як це роблять в країнах
Європейських такі парламентські бюлетені
які або Європарламенту які існують
тільки як в інтернеті або як
youtube-канали ну і важлива одна дуже
новина Сьогодні ми зібрали 226 голосів
навіть 227 голосів які підписалися під
закликом до голови Верховної Ради
України негайно винести на
пленарне засідання так звані церковні
закони ці закони законопроекти в тому
числі європейської солідарності які
забороняють
існування Московської церкви - це фсбної
структури під прикриттям на території
України нагадаю що і голова Верховної
Ради не вносив їх в порядок денний
мовляв немає на це голосів Отже голоси є
не тепер будемо дивитися що зараз
вигадає пан стефанчук бачите він
Президії і керівництво слух які
блокували винесення цих законопроектів
на засідання Верховної Ради Ну от бачимо
зараз да і Олексій Гончаренко і Мої
колеги ще і ще раз наголошують на наших
поправках що стосуються підтримки
збройних сил України бо це не нормально
коли у нас сьогодні зарплати в бепах
інших там оце при працівних органах а по
100 тисяч на місяць в там наглядових
радах домільйона доходять і оце от все
голосується зараз е-е змінами до бюджету
це час як на збройні сили на дрони у нас
Ну немає ми знаємо коштів друзі
підписуйтесь на мої носії електронні на
YouTube канал на telegram-канал тому що
Повірте там більше інформації в тому
числі про роботу парламенту Ну а нові
обличчя яким На жаль мільйони українців
повірили що вони будуть демонструвати
нову політичну культуру нову звитягу
бачимо прогулюють просто засідання
Верховної Ради був не працюють це все
дуже і дуже сумно